[Musique]
je la fine
c'est un clip pour éveiller les
consciences
comme chaque année l'association belge
alicante diffuse un spot publicitaire
pour dénoncer l'inégalité hommes femmes
en matière salariale
ici un jeune homme épouse une femme âgée
mais rapidement le conte de fée vire au
drame et le mari décide de commettre
l'irréparable
[Musique]
au moment du passage chez le notaire
c'est la déception une manière décalée
d'évoquer des retraites bien plus faible
chez les femmes conséquence logique des
différences de salaires sa diffusion est
prévue pour l'equal pay day jour qui
correspond chaque année à la date
jusqu'à laquelle les femmes devraient
travailler en plus pour toucher autant
que les hommes
cette année en belgique c'est le 14 mars
soit 20 % d'écart salarial depuis 13 ans
maintenant
et quand tu as choisi ce mode de
communication pour sensibiliser au sujet
par rapport à ce problème là n'est pas
très grande
donc pour vraiment créer un effet choc
pour vraiment en dire aux gens il ya un
problème les résoudre c'est bien de
faire bouger les choses de choquer mais
on reste toujours positif on n'entre
jamais dans la négativité le but c'est
de rester voilà d'avoir une touche
légère dont la campagne aussi le
problème dreyer est assez grave par
contre en belgique l'écart salarial est
donc de 20 % mais seulement 2 6% si l'on
prend les salaires à temps de travail
égal
la faute notamment à un temps partiel
souvent subie chez les femmes mais des
réseaux se développe pour renforcer leur
place dans les entreprises chez jump
c'est même devenu une raison d'être ici
on dispense des formations
on accompagne des entreprises et on
organise des forums pour partager les
bonnes pratiques
on va faire un petit point de l'état la
désinscription du forum parce que c'est
dans une semaine pour sa fondatrice
c'est un investissement de tous les
acteurs qui doit inciter aux bonnes
pratiques
c'est comme une voiture sur une pente
on n'a pas tout le temps le pied sur
l'accélérateur la voiture elle va
reculer automatiquement donc je pense
que c'est vraiment une attention des
politiques
une attention de la société civile qui
met la pression sur les entreprises qui
leur font savoir que c'est devenu
totalement intolérable pour le public
pour les citoyens de savoir qu'une femme
qui travaille de la même façon qu'un
homme qui a les mêmes qualifications
n'est pas payée de la même façon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des entreprises qui s'engagent il y en a
en belgique chez atlan société
spécialisée dans le financement de
location de voitures longue durée le
general manager a même été désigné
ambassadeur pour l'égalité
professionnelle grâce à des mesures très
simples à mettre en place toute la nuit
et nous ne démarre pas avant que on la
possibilité de chaque chez les enfants
ou les déposer à l'école
quand il ya une enfant malade il n'y a
pas d'explication à donner on peut on
peut rester à la maison et donc il ya
plein de petits règles qu'on a mis en
place pour faciliter la balance et
privés et professionnels une nouvelle
culture dans l'entreprise qui lui sert
aussi à se démarquer face à des
concurrents et donc à attirer des
talents
cette image de société un peu une vente
dans sa réflexion mais aussi qui cherche
vraiment à réinventer la manière de
travailler nous aident à recruter des
profils dans lequel on pouvait que rêver
avant et et c'est réussi
des pratiques qui commence à séduire de
plus en plus d'entreprises
même si les gars salariale entre femmes
et hommes se réduit trop lentement
d'où l'urgence pour certains politiques
de prendre de nouvelles mesures plus
coercitives notamment au niveau européen
il ya une directive qui est sur la table
du conseil donc des états membres depuis
cinq ans et qui est la directive des
femmes dans les conseils
d'administration qui irait vers une
représentation de femmes dans les
conseils d'administration aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment bloquant et je trouve
qu'on doit faire des campagnes beaucoup
plus forte personne ne sait que cette
initiative est bloqué par les états
membres
en france une loi oblige les plus
grandes entreprises à avoir au moins 40
% de membres femmes dans leur conseil
d'administration
une mesure que l'europe pourrait
généraliser et étendre à toutes les
entreprises quelle que soit leur taille
[Musique]